hey what is up guys mpbhd here and you
know how for the past year or so pretty
much every smartphone that's come out
has had some sort of notch in the top in
the middle that's just the way they've
been i've said it before and i'll say it
again the most interesting designs that
we've seen for the past couple months
were smartphones trying to avoid the
notch
well looks like for 2018
that
that's gonna be how we get away from it
that's the avoidance of the notch so
this is what i'm going to call the hole
punch so yes of course different
companies are going to call it different
things samsung will call it the infinity
o display this one we have here is the
honor view 20 from huawei they don't
really call it anything so we'll just
call it the hole punch so there's all
kinds of interesting things about this
phone from the blue chevron back that
changes the way it looks depending on
how light hits it which is really cool
to the 4 000 milliamp hour battery to
the 48 megapixel main camera the six
gigs of ram
but what i'm here for is the hole punch
display so this particular version of
the hole punch is through an lcd display
so not an oled and it's a 6.4 inch 2310
by 1080 display so not the highest
resolution but it looks alright and you
can see that they've pushed it to the
edges like a lot of other phones this
past year but instead of having a notch
for the front facing camera they've gone
all the way up to the corner and there's
this hole punch cut out in the top left
corner of the display so as far as we
can tell this is the future of
smartphone design avoiding the notch in
2019. we knew it was coming and it's one
thing to see the leaks and the renders
and another to actually see it in person
the first thing that strikes me is it's
bigger than i thought it would be i mean
i saw the renders and i think they were
a little generous with how small they
thought the aperture for the camera
opening would need to be but putting in
a full camera module means you'll need
the full camera opening and it's
noticeable but you know still not too
bad but then other things i noticed were
really specific to this exact phone's
implementation of the notch for example
it's not centered even in the rounded
corner of the display it's a little bit
above center to be tucked further into
the notification bar so as not to
interrupt apps below it which makes
sense but it's really hard to unnotice
that it's not centered and i kind of
wish i didn't notice that like as part
of the aesthetic of the phone it just
looks a little bit off and then there's
also a slightly darkened area around the
hole punch as if there's a little added
shadow surrounding it i reached out to
huawei about this and they haven't
gotten back to me yet but i'll add a
pinned comment or a tweet or something
if i do but as of right now i think it's
added in the software because there are
other places in the ui where there's a
similar shadow added like the bottom of
the display in party mode or even in the
launcher or on other huawei apps if that
darkened area is because of like the way
the display is built because of the
hardware or the way the lcd and the
backlight work that's a different story
that oled may be able to solve when we
see it in future phones but as of right
now it appears to just be with this
phone and the fact that the whole rest
of the notification bar is shaded it's
you kind of don't really notice it after
a while anyway but if you look at it for
long enough you will notice and then
overall you got to think about apps and
so far apps play with the hole punch
pretty much the same way that they
played with the regular notch meaning
they ignore the whole space all the way
up at the top there's a section in
huawei's settings they still call it a
notch but they let you hide the notch
like always that just blacks out the
whole top of the phone and for the most
part full screen apps play pretty well
with it with literally just a hole in
the ui just a hole in the app simple as
that you can watch videos with a hole in
the screen you can play games with a
hole in the screen it's something to get
used to just like the notch and there
are also some apps that do look kind of
weird right now because of things like
text up in the corners or some weird
overlapping elements things that
wouldn't have looked quite as weird with
a regular notch in the middle but again
i think people will get used to it and
apps will update as well but yeah that's
as far as the hole punch that's pretty
much it i think the more phones that we
see start to do this hole punch camera
cut out the more clever ways we'll see
of hiding that hole punch and with like
things like dark wallpapers and clever
gradients and things like that but now
what we got to stay tuned to find out is
what other phones will have the hole
punch cut out so there was the huawei
nova 4 that was at ces that had the hole
punch already that i got to hold and
take photos of and play with briefly
that's going to go on sale and of course
we all just saw the samsung galaxy s10
event that got announced for the end of
february we're all expecting that to
have not only a single camera cut out
but the larger one should have a dual
camera cut out so we'll get to see how
the highest end displays will work with
oled and twice as big of a camera cut
out i'm super ready for that and i still
i still wish someone would do it in the
middle like there's no notifications in
the middle there's time isn't in the
middle that's where no information
usually needs to be that's where the
notch usually was
but as of right now it seems like the
corner cutout is the most popular
implementation
of avoiding the notch in 2019
welcome to the new year either way let
me know what you think would you rock
this phone with the cool sparkly back
would you rock any phone with a hole
punch cutout in it let me know what you
think in the comments below thanks for
watching
catch you guys the next one
peace